You know, so I'm going to,
I, I work in a lot of fields,
but I would also consider
myself an astrobiologist. Right?
Which is a pretty kind of wild idea that
you can do astrobiology even though you
only have one example,
which is the earth.
But we've learned so much and now we
can start asking ourselves about the
possibility of life elsewhere. So finding
even a microbe like even of Friggin,
you know, Amoeba on Mars would be, or
even evidence that there used to be me,
but it's hard is the evidence
that they've discovered on Mars.
What they found was, um,
organic chemistry, right?
And so our but organic chemistry and I
hated chemistry when I was growing up. Uh,
and I hated our getting again,
was that just basically chemistry
involved in carbon, you know,
so you can have non,
or you know,
he does organic chemistry
doesn't mean organisms,
but it's the kind of chemistry
that organisms live. Right?
So finding evidence that there was
like they drilled and they said like,
we send a freaking robot to Mars, they
could drill through a rock, you know,
and then in just the rocket and then
send the data back, cross space,
you know, pretty good for a bunch
of hairless apes. Yeah. Um, so what,
what they found was evidence
for fairly complex, um, uh,
you know, uh, organic chemistry, which
meant that way back when Mars and this,
we know for sure, right? Mars had water
on it. We know that for sure. Now Morris,
it was a blue planet for at least Mars
was hit by an asteroid or a common or
something along those lines. Everything
got hit by comments. That's how we have,
you know, we have chunks of Mars
here, right? That, you know,
the thing in [inaudible] 96 or
whatever, when they were like, oh,
we found life on Mars.
You know,
they thought that what they found was a
fossil bacteria in a chunk of our Mars
that they found in an article.
So the planets had been swapping spit
for like the entire history of the solar
systems, fossilized bacteria that they
found is that been confirmed? No, of it.
Most people now think that the Allen
Hills, uh, media, right. That probably,
you know, it's inconclusive and it's
not conclusive enough to be like, yeah,
we found life. It's like a
tiny little squiggly worm
look. And that's what it was.
Yeah.
But it was so small that it was like
way smaller than any of the microscopic
fossilized bacteria we've
ever seen before. So people
in general are like me. Um,
but by fine, but that's what started,
right. That's when Clinton was like, okay,
we're going to send a lot
of shit tomorrow. Cause
after, you know, back in 90,
you're early nineties,
people were kind of done with Mars.
And so that's what triggered the whole,
you know, one space probe after another,
the rovers and like,
so you know,
the thing we found was a
direct result of that effort,
which was this organic chemistry,
which says that back in the day Mars had
had a lot of this stuff lying around,
had a lot of these, you know, these,
these organic chemicals line
around which if your life,
that's what you're going to be using.
So that's like one more step.
Like we've been putting up the Lego blocks
for the argument for life on Mars one
piece at a time since the, you know,
since the first rovers went there. Yeah.
If we did discover just even
plants on some other planet,
even just a planet with some
sort of plant like life. Yeah,
that would be, that'd be a
game changer. Game Changer.
Because we don't know if
there's, we've, you know,
are we the only time in the entire history
of the universe that like this crazy
thing where got,
we went from non life to life.
Like is that common or is that never ever,
ever happen.
So that's the question we want to, you
know, we want to answer and I, you know,
I mean like,
you know,
that argument I was given before is
I think from the probable arguments,
I'm saying it's like, you know, it's,
it's almost overwhelming that you had
probably happened somewhere. Again,
it doesn't mean anything is here,
but we need evidence. Right. Science.
So we got to build that evidence.
Yeah. And if we do find something, the,
the,
the one of the weirder things would be
if we found something and there was a way
to get there. Yeah. You know, we, we
find something and we're like, yeah,
we find something,
but it's,
we're pretty sure there's some kind of
life and it's 3 billion light years away.
Like wow, that's cool.
Yeah. What do we do? Yeah.
It's nice to know that
we're not the only ones.
It's interesting like how much
would that change, you know,
even if we found like evidence for this,
cause this is a debate.
Like if we found evidence of
a technological civilization
we saw like alien mega
structures, like that star
they felt was that nonsense.
And it wasn't really nonsense. It
was something floating around. Right?
So here's what they
saw. So that, you know,
the way we discover planets is we look
for when the planet passes in front of
the star, you get a little
dip in the light, right?
It blocks out a little bit of light, took
a little eclipse. Um, and so, you know,
we've now, that's how we should know
that every star in the sky has planets,
but there's like,
they found one that just make no sense.
Like the light would dip
then what stopped it?
And then it would dip again three
times and it would stopped dipping.
Sometimes it was lower, sometimes it was
higher. Um, and you know, for a year.
So people were like, fuck
it. You know? And so, uh,
Jason Wright and others, a,
Jason's a friend of mine, you know,
they wrote a paper where they
were like, hey, you know,
at least cause this is what the future's
gonna look like. We can't say, we can't,
we have to at least consider the
possibility that these are artificial
structures that are like
orbiting the star, you know?
And would have to be ungodly, huge,
ungodly, huge alien mega structures.
Like that's the best word ever. Like the
size of a country, right? Yeah. Yeah.
These things would be huge. Right?
But that's what people think. Like,
you know when people think about
advanced alien civilizations,
the idea of building large
scale structures is you
think that maybe the next
thing you do once you reach
a certain point, like, um,
you know, the Dyson sphere,
the idea that you could collect all of
the sun's energy and use it for yourself
by building a giant sphere around the
sun with solar panels on the inside.
People think like that
goes back to car to chefs.
They idea of this Carter chef scale
back in the 60s where he's like, look,
there's going to be a natural progression
of civilizations that goes first.
You collect all the energy you can from
your planet and then you use that to do
amazing things.
And then you collect all the energy
from your star and then you do that.
You know, you do amazing shit with that.
And then you know, the whole galaxy.
So he know Carter Chef thought there
was a scale that that civilizations
naturally progress through and hopefully
don't blow yourself up along the way.
Well, I think that's the question.
I mean, I've criticized the,
the chef scale in one of the papers I
recently did because what it fails to take
into account is the fact that like,
you know,
on your way up to the type one type one
is when you harvest all the energy from
your planet, which basically means
somehow covering your planet in, uh,
solar panels or something that neglects
what we've learned since Carter Chef
wrote his paper in 64, he said, you
know, planets don't like that shit.
Like planets, the plants going to feed
back. You try and build, you know,
massive shit on your planet. The
planet has its own, you know,
biospheres pretty powerful and you've
got to take the biosphere and account or
you get climate change.
You get had the planet being pushed off
in another direction. So, but whatever.
So for the, um, for the alien mega
structures, people thought like, oh,
maybe this is like a piece of an, uh,
of a Dyson sphere. Right? This is like,
you know, that's so, you
know, when he proposed this,
people went bonkers over this.
Right. You were just
saying, he's like, look,
here's the 15 different things could
be and I'm going to have to at least
consider the possibility that
it's artificial. Um, but for me,
and some people got really
angry at everything,
but I felt like this is what they get
angry because there's been a thing in the
community over the years, you know,
said he got a bad name, right.
Setting for a bunch of [inaudible]. He
was sort of thought as being like, oh,
only whackadoodles do that and why?
Why is that?
Just because there was no results. Ah, I
just think, you know, there was, you know,
it is, it's because of Shitty
TV, you know? I mean, I
really, in some ways, right?
It's all, you know, it's prosthetic
foreheads, right? It's the whole,
we've had so much kind of crappy,
you know, speculation about aliens.
They're trying to do anything scientific.
Always had this whiff of sort
of being a little, you know,
and then there's the Ufo stuff,
which is completely separate as
nothing to do with it. Let's see.
Seti never really achieved any results,
right?
There was that one big blip that
was highly popularized. Wow. Signal.
But here's the thing about setting,
we never really did set he that much.
You know what I mean? Like
people have this idea like, wow,
we've got telescopes all over the
world and they're looking at, you know,
the government never funded a study study.
I bet. Anything Major, right? So people,
you know, the, all that said he has
done is like basically, you know,
some dudes on a telescope get a little
extra time like, hey man, I'll quick,
let's go look at a star. Right? You know,
Jill Tarter, who's one of the founders,
one of the greats of Seti, she
compares it. It's like, you know,
we've got an ocean that we
need to look at and we've,
so far we've looked at a thimble,
right? But she, the Jodie foster care,
the Jody foster character, yet we're in
contact. Yeah. Yeah. So she's laying on,
it's a good point. Like we haven't really
looked yet. So the idea that, you know,
the stars are silent or anything,
it's like, man, come on.
We haven't even begun to
do a comprehensive service.